today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza you know it today's
episode is brought to you by Ridge
wallet if you find something in your
back pocket that's probably your wallet
I mean that's could be something else
but 90% chant 95 percent chance it's
your wallet or someone's wallet if you
picked up someone else's wallet on
accident but that's a old-school man
carrying a big lump in the back of your
pants brother what are you what are you
dude some kind of camel get your life
better and buy better I mean get that
Ridge wallet and the ridge wallet is a
front pocket carry and it's that little
you know it's that front area bad boy
and it holds your credit cards it's got
that money clip get the one with the
money clip that's my favorite in the
back and they also got a knife so you
can get a beautiful knife get that you
know that nook nook you know you know
I'm saying do your own dental work or if
somebody tries to steal your Ridge
wallet that front pocket carry hit them
with that nuke nuke and you can go to
Ridge wallet dot-com slash Theo and use
the code Theo th EO for 10% off
that's Ridge wallet comm slash Theo
carry your stuff in the front stat on
the back of your own pants with sub you
coma roamers what's up you sleepy
creepies wake up man get your mind up
get your brain up get your chest up you
know I'm saying pension nipples dog bite
your tongue you know I'm saying flex
your holes bruh you got this we got this
you know I'm that nightmare teddy bear
baby I'm that I'm that Freddy Ruxpin
let's go
[Music]
she was hotter than the blacktop broke
down at a truck stop she looked about as
wild as the story she told
[Music]
says she was a Christian saving souls in
Savannah and the Lord senator Alan bear
[Applause]
[Music]
long-haired dog Ruth seemed like she was
in a hurry I'll then a junkie tried out
in the slammer Lord I hope I don't die
an Alabama
and that's a little bit gun right there
with Alabama and and and that uh that
that music video is coming out in a few
weeks I'm gonna be in the head dude I
got it you know I told you guys a while
back I got to be in that music video
with the Bishop gun and I play a arm you
know pretty much a young fellow you know
a lightly aged gentleman you know you
know still kind of strong in the skin
but also kind of nervous in the spirit
and I am I'm on the run from literally
on the run from the dark arts at Dan and
Alabama so that was a beautiful time
that I had with them boy that was just a
real just joyous occasion like somebody
just sprinkles sugar all inside of my
damn heart what's up good to see you
guys this episode is always brought to
you by great block pizza so I'm gonna
put that in and I and they're at 1811
Pico Boulevard in Los Angeles and I just
got back from Toronto in Toronto I was
at the Just for Laughs comedy festival
and they say festival but it seemed like
a little bit of like a scam where the
disusing comedians to sell tickets
honestly and the shows are great it's
still great it's great for the fans that
come out you know it's great for that
curious crew that come out to see me and
they go see anybody but I just felt like
the jf the company didn't put on much of
a festival I didn't think you know I
mean I saw a couple you know they had um
they had a homeless dude out there
looking for his friend and you know for
three days when every time I go outside
this dude asked me if I seen this friend
and I don't know you know I don't know
if these you know these wild cats have
been playing hide-and-go-seek since the
since the 90s or what but this you know
he's like hey have you seen my friend
you know if you see my friend you know
he has kind of long hair but it's also
kind of short on the sides and I'm like
who has long hair but
short on the sides and then I'm thinking
oh [ __ ] that's that's me maybe this man
is looking for me
but anyway so yeah if that's the
festival some dude looking for his
friend then that was the festival but
the city itself you know I really can't
speak highly look I love America I'm
happy to be American I'm grateful to be
American I don't exist if I'm not here
this is my place and time in my place
you know on this earth this is the you
know the cubicle of earth that I came
into was through that you know that red
white and blue buckle you know this is
the this is the pathway that I came into
existence was through America but but
Canada is a great place man I mean and
Toronto dude it's so diverse let me tell
you that do you if you're racist you
couldn't even figure out who to hate
this is the most diverse place you ever
seen man they got everything out there
they got uh one dude said he was
jalapeno I'm like what is that they got
a dude he was polish and Pomeranian you
know they got what Japanese sri lankan
somebody said he's Sri Lankan and I'm
like mountain climbing rappelling some
dude said he was um you know I think he
said he was a Serbian macchiato like
what is that dude it's diver I mean yes
bro it is diverse they got everything
and that's why I say beige power the
future is beige baby the future is beige
yeah so base our but yeah people were
just so friendly I mean you know
Canada's a kind of place somebody will
break into your house and install an
alarm
you're like you'll be in your club like
he somebody would would you'd have some
dude hidin in your closet with a knife
in Canada and he would come out and be
like hey eh um I just yeah I was I just
here was just sharpening your knives for
you here's one and you're like wow
like he thought he's gonna stab you but
he's just he been sharpening all your
knives that's what he was doing you know
and also maybe had you know it's just
his uh man it's just people are just
friendly you could get shot and killed
bruh probably by a stray bullet from
another country maybe from North Korea a
stray bullet comes across the
stratosphere hits you in Canada you're
dying in the street and a Canadian would
come up to him but like II um do you
have a do you still have a busy day
ahead and you'd be like yeah yeah I have
a lot I had a lot of stuff to do later
today but I'm I'm dying and they're like
um a well I'll die for you you know why
don't you just go on about your day and
I'll just lay here and die for you if
you don't mind like uh okay like that's
Canada somebody will just die for you
because they don't want just too nice
you die literally I was out last night
what'd I do thank you to everybody that
came out man great great great great
people came out you know and not fans I
don't like to think of like fans you
know I think of people that come out a
little bit more like a curious crew
because that's when I think of myself as
being like a fan of something really I'm
just curious about it you know I've
talked about that before I'm just kind
of curiosity has been enveloped you know
we're summoned by something and so you
know we had a beautiful curious crew of
characters that came out to the shows
and yeah man I got to be at this place
called the Winter Garden and they got
trees they got foliage up in the ceiling
so they got you know Johnny Appleseed
was just I don't know if he was on some
[ __ ] MDMA or something you know and
he just puts up it's just suction cups
on his feet and just
you know went wall-to-wall but they have
they have all kinds of trees and plants
hanging from all the ceiling in there so
it's really an I mean it was a beautiful
theater and it was one of my first
experiences in a theater you know I
performed in South Africa a couple years
ago in in a humongous theatre there but
it had been a long time and that was
part of a festival there down in non
Johannesburg but this was man this was
nice and it was just good people what
else what else happened over there um oh
well yeah with Nick Swardson and Nick
Swardson is like a little kind of you
know he's like seven years old and also
you know like 40 years old so he's like
47 years old like he has like I've never
been around anybody that made me laugh
more than that guy he literally told me
stories about him being set on fire he
had some great stories about just when
he was coming up in comedy and the
different in different people he would
see man it was just great I had a great
time I got - who else was there I don't
really see any other comedians and there
wasn't like a bunch of big hangouts you
know it wasn't really like I didn't feel
like a festival but it was a good time
and thank you to all the curious crew
that came out and enjoyed it you know
with the let you know the Late Show on
set the the show on set on Saturday was
at midnight and people stayed around
after and hung out my boy Dickie Klum he
used to play up there or he plays up
there he plays he plays hockey for the
Toronto and he came out and and it was
just good you know I just felt great man
I so many people just like gave me hugs
and you know it made me feel really
really uplifted and I just thank you so
much but damn if you want to be in
diversity do you want to see the future
and see it be comfortable and fun
there's just no there's some
about Canada where I you just don't
there's something America where you feel
dislike people's got this chip on their
shoulder and I can't really I don't know
where it comes from you know I think
it's a distrust almost and I don't know
if it's something that's just that we
feel from as much from real interactions
that we've had or if we feel it from
because the pressure from like you know
our news and our and our media always
saying that everything is so wrong but
when you get to Canada man it's like
this ninth layer of skin that you that
that like this nervous energy this it
falls off you if I can't like it falls
off you just don't feel as fearful and
you just feel more relaxed and you walk
down the street and there's oh people is
beautiful in Toronto if you live in a
place and everybody's ugly you know
we're not real super handsome you know
we're if you live in a house and your
family don't have you know y'all
genetics is real it's real touch-and-go
in the DNA at your house you know maybe
I'll got a couple stepmoms that's also
you know you know you you know your
grandfather or whatever who knows and
everybody got kind of whiskers and you
know maybe your mother gots a sideburn
growing out on right under her chin who
knows bra because a lot of them you know
they got a lot of they got a lot of
twisted bad girls up in the Catskills
and that you know a lot of at you know
them Adirondacks snow kittens out there
and then bad [ __ ] up there they'll
grow a [ __ ] sideburn right up on her
neck they don't care you know some
ladies down there in Florida they had
too much sunshine and their chest is
starting to que it looked like somebody
melted a piece of uh cheese right here
in between their breasts and I don't
know what that's cold I don't know
you know I'm not a doctor I'm not
especially I'm not about them caso
diseases you know but they definitely
you'll see a lot of ladies out there
you'll see a lot of ladies out there if
you're down to Florida and no disrespect
to it but a lot of ladies they got that
it looked like somebody melted a couple
of pieces of velvetta right there wrists
right up between their tat tits and you
like to him and you look if you and if
you drunk enough you might just want to
order a side of chips and just dip them
and hit them to test with that chip chat
boy and treat your throat to something
[ __ ] test st you know put that taste
test in your throat because some of them
ladies got that velvetta that melted
Velveeta you know that uh that you know
titty canal and that's from too much
sunshine and so you know I'm just saying
anyway you got a lot of you know and
they got some time you'll see a dude and
he got saw you know we had a guy in our
neighborhood growing up this guy what
the what was that dude's name brah
captain Randall and his parents I
remember I heard later is his parents
they couldn't decide to name him Daniel
or Randy so they named him ran yo and
then he he said he was a captain but
really he just found a hat that was a
captain's hat you know people like that
you know somebody find a shirt and the
next thing you know they say that they
are you know a business person or
whatever
so but anyway captain Randall would he
had this big mole growing up the side of
his neck and he developed this a little
bit of a nervous condition where every
time he would press it that's when he
would talk so it was almost this sort of
it was like he would listen to you while
you were talking and then he pressed on
the mole and talked almost like he was
am a little machine you know it was kind
of crazy if you can see on the YouTube
I'm kind of interact
reenacting it for you you'd be like
what's going on captain and and then he
would press the mole and talk to you as
if he was like a had a
walkie-talkie built into his neck but it
was just some mom you know it was just
what is a mole you know a mole is just
you know it's sometimes a mole can just
be it's like a little you know it's like
the devil kinda you know it's like a
little bullet point from the devil just
reminding you that you he might give you
cancer if you don't keep your act
together but but yet but dude in Toronto
everybody got to nice posture dude you
could look if say if you're walking down
the street and you got a couple books
you can't carry them all you could set a
book on like eight people's head and
just walk next to them for a while and
you next thing you know they got they're
caring they don't even notice dude
everybody has good posture I don't know
if this is the posture belt or if you
know some people they might have you
know one or two somebodies you know
great granddaddy was a lemur cuz if you
see a lemur boy a lemur is like three
feet tall in their feet is only about an
inch long
can you imagine holding up a three feet
tall body with a foot that is only a
damn inch that's power that's posture
and power but that's what you see in
Toronto just people you could set out
the thirty books you could [ __ ] run a
Barnes & Noble off a bunch of people's
craniums and they wouldn't even know
y'all is cruising down the block just
like a like a just like a bunch of just
just book heads but beautiful people in
Toronto and they take care of themselves
that's a thing man they the people in
Toronto they take care of themselves and
they look and they just I and I'm not
look I'm not dissing on America but I'm
just telling you things that I noticed
when I'm there I feel this man this is a
visceral feeling that I feel and people
are friendly and you'll see a pretty
girl and she don't act like she's pretty
you know you see a pretty girl in
America and she'd be throwing these you
know she don't even have eyes in her
face she just got these straight-up
[ __ ] you know these [ __ ] casters she
just shooting you know - [ __ ] bullets
right at you
just manche manche manche be vvvvvv baby
baby baby baby itch every time they look
around and it's bent bent bands bands
everywhere they gaze at a shooting
[ __ ] you know just you know better
than you lasers be [ __ ] be you [ __ ]
I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] just because they have
a nice look to them but you're in
Toronto you see a beautiful lady man and
they look like they might be nice and
they look like they're beauty ain't
their own ain't their number one
attribute that their Blue Ribbon is
pinned to another part of their
personality or to an actual part of
their personality not just that exterior
motif and I found that to be very you
know it made me feel a little bit
I guess it made me feel kind of less
than in a way cuz I built myself up in
this American Way you know I build
myself up in this like I don't know it
made me feel like wow this is more I'd
like to be like this
like to be like it just felt more
sincere caring sincere it made me think
maybe this is what America used to be
like but then also I romanticize America
a lot of times I romanticized the past
you know I think of the past as being
like you know a special time or a great
time and I wasn't even there so but
again I had a great time in the city I
had a great time with the people and I
had a great time with Canada I'll come
back a million times thank you guys so
much for for having me that song on the
way in that was Alabama Bishop gun in
the video that I did with them is gonna
be coming out here in like a week or so
so I just wanted to remind you and let
you guys just get another listen to that
and that's such a beautiful group man
out of there out of Natchez and what
else is going on I'll tell you this that
if you if you see me looking swaggy
right now that's because I have on I'll
show you my hair right now it's really
clutched up because it's under this hat
but when my hair isn't under a hat
that's because I'm using beardbrand and
I use that old money sea salt spray that
double up I hit that double pump in the
daddies you know when the daddy's full
flow and beer brands premium men's
grooming for beard hair and skin and
that's all you have is a man you have
beard you have hair you have skin then
you have you know these extremities in
this Annette you got that see Rotch and
that back outlet spout and that's it
but beardbrand is based out of Austin
Texas and it's formulated products to
work with that man's body cuz a man's
body you know it's got that we got that
you know that by going on and so you
don't want to be putting on this stuff
and feel like a woman's thing you know
you barn deodorant it's got a picture of
a little you know maybe a unicorn or you
know two women fighting outside of a
nail salon
on the front of it no you want men's
stuff and beer brand it is that stuff
and it fosters confidence through
grooming take care of yourself man your
own ship with that beer brand and it's
more than just products it's education
its inspiration in its community so make
sure to grab a utility ball you can use
something you can use your own your hair
you can use it on the skin you can use
it you could balm up your [ __ ] your
eyelids and treat yourself you know to
just clutch it suddenly you know what
I'm saying you're Daniel day lovely and
that's what beer brain can do for you
your head - beer brand calm slash Theo
today for a free sample of sea salt
spray beardbrand dot-com / Theo make you
believe this that it is only 95 days
until Christmas and it's right around
the corner Christmas your universe
recommender Tumtum donors were Maj do
Christmas is crazy your family member
shows up and they all hopped up on drugs
and trying to pretend that they're not
you know the children come downstairs
and they don't even like what they got
in a pissed bra
you know one of them we used to have a
my neighbor's bringing a kid over and
all Christmas dude we didn't know it for
years but he would sneak around the
house and pissed behind some of the um
you know furniture pieces and wall
pieces and this dude was always pissing
in our plants and everything like that
every time he come over years later he
got into a 12-step program and he came
by the house and told us like I didn't
how to accept that I mean I'm all I'm
all about forgiveness but somebody comes
because they would come over every
Christmas
they would come over out every Christmas
man just lady Miss Danielle her husband
Stanley and the kids name what was that
kid's name it was like a knot rope it
was lariat they had this little boy
lariat and he had kind of a arm he was
uh he seen you if something was [ __ ]
wrong with this dude bro he was haunted
I think and I don't know I'm not you
know I'm not that spiritual Wildcat you
know I'm not the kind of dude I don't
have genie lamps at my house or you know
or have different types of you know geo
geo geo tees those crystals are you know
the zygotes or whatever frozen zygotes
and [ __ ] in the freezer I don't do all
of that you know I'm not a real say on
sir but this little [ __ ] bro this
dude look haunted you know it seemed
like he didn't even blink just like
every now and then he put in eyedrops
you know and Larry it with some sneak
off he came and I guess he got a little
toast our program and he came back and
told us he'd been pissing behind
everything in our house and I was a
bed-wetter so respected it but at the
same time I'm like damn boy you just
don't know who you having over you know
you don't know who you haven't over
somebody comes over and they you know
they hide all your groceries and [ __ ]
around the house and I'm saying you know
you just don't know who you don't know
who sometimes who people are so that you
just got only person you could really
really know as yourself that's the only
person you can really really know as
yourself but winners come in Santa's
coming you know we got to get through
some of these other holidays first we
got Halloween we got this and that but
back here in America I want to
congratulate Cleveland Baker Mayfield
boy Baker Mayfield imagine coming into a
professional game
[Music]
and leading your team to a victory I
mean that's like our that's our knight
in shining armor moment of these days
you know that's our that is it and Baker
Mayfield did that for the Cleveland
Browns Cleveland hadn't won a game I
wrote it down here Cleveland hadn't won
a game in 21 months can you even him
dance I imagine being pregnant for 21
months you know you're trying you're
taking the vitamins you know you're
taking the horsehair pills or whatever
these ladies are taking you know you eat
know you know taking these little guava
packets to the jaw and stuff like that
and extra vitamin D suppositories or
whatever them little butt buddies or
whatever you put in to get the extra
vitamins near the baby imagine being
pregnant for 21 months and delivering
and just every week you think you're
gonna deliver something you think you're
gonna deliver a victory and then your
womb takes another L nope and you got a
key nope not yet not yet not yet
that's Cleveland Browns and Baker may
feel shut up he put on them gloves dr.
Baker
dr. Baker is here and he just he did and
he delivered that hitter man that's
powerful so congratulations to Cleveland
man I know what you know and it's tough
when you're a big fan of sports and your
team doesn't do well for a long time
congratulations to Tiger Woods you know
everybody loves a comeback everybody
loves an underdog and that man hasn't
given up for a long time and I think
they said it was his first major victory
since 2013
so look kudos Congrats
you know people everybody wants to you
know some people want to hold that man
his whole life again you know he cheated
he ran around and man we're all fallible
we're all broken people out here trying
to be puzzle pieces and trying to fit
and and a leopard can't change his spots
I don't know what Tigers love life is
like or anything like that I don't care
I'll uh I'll like seen him as an athlete
and kudos to him for getting it done bro
getting it done what else is going on oh
I read this Japan successfully landed
two unmanned Rovers on a asteroid I can
you can you even think the deuteron that
is basically remember that movie with
Leonardo who was in it Leonardo not
Leonardo DiCaprio Steve Buscemi Steve
Buscemi dying um mmm who was in it
Michael Lawson or whatever I don't know
Armageddon that was the movie Steve
Buscemi and uh I think Michael West
Dutton or something Charles s Dutton
the guy from Rudy that claps the black
eye that claps he they saved the planet
and they landed on an asteroid that was
a movie ten to 15 years ago now that is
a Japanese reality so if you see
something suiting across the star across
the sky dude that's and that's the don't
that's not it and that's not just a
shooting star anymore that's it that's
that new Japanese rodeo okay I'm telling
you boy
then Janie's are turning up and they're
doing it out in the atmosphere
imagine that Blaine and you know one of
them dudes snuck off and bust at a nudie
Newt can you tell are you serious you
telling me you're on an asteroid you're
flying at the speed of light brah and
you ain't going just twist one off and
just let that [ __ ] hit the air hit the
space you would imagine you're see just
out in space brah
imagine your seed just floating through
the just lands in some you know out in
vegeto or something some new planet you
know or vag a turn and it lands in a
something over there a little squirt you
know uh a little squirrels mouth or a
little octopus or something this you
know sucking on a [ __ ] little you
know meaty or nugget or something over
on the on the front of Saturn and then
you you know then you got that space
schism out there lands up in its and
it's you know orifice and next thing you
know brah you might have something way
out there a new family member who knows
who knows right now I'm drinking this
I'm also drinking Bixby I'm drinking
Bixby coffee and I know that they've
been our small business uh you know we
take in a small business every now and
then and we and we help advertise for
them and that's Bixby coffee and it's
coffee you can make at home because
coffee shops you know who they're for
the rich brah coffee shops are for who
yasiel puig Martha Stewart's probably
goes to a coffee shop who else
[Music]
off Fred Astaire or his children he died
but his children probably go to coffee
shops and most homemade coffees are
stale because they don't make them there
they make them somewhere else they make
them in Michigan they make them in you
know part of IATA but this is the real
deal this is high-end coffee that's more
affordable than grocery store coffee and
that's bixby it's shipped to your door
the day it is roasted dude that's crazy
brah that's like a drug dealer but the
drug is L cafe it's better coffee at a
better price delivered right to your
doorstep
Bix peak coffee calm use promo code Theo
th EO at checkout and your first
shipment cost just $5 that's two weeks
of coffee for $5 using promo code Theo
promo code Theo at checkout for shipment
just five dollars go to Bigsby coffee
calm and thank you for that I put that
almond milk in mine dude almond milk
that's crazy man almond milk when you
think about it I can't believe that
they're milking almonds okay what you
know I think about you know they got
vegans and vegetarians and all of that
you know uh whatever these people are
who ever is you know from Vietnam or
whatever but I don't you know and I want
to be supportive but dude there we all
are milk and almonds they have almond
milk
dude when I first of all when I was
young they I remember that almond joy
remember almond joy almonds was having
fun almonds were just laying on coconut
just pouring they had chocolate all over
their bodies they had two of them on a
coconut they had a little amigo up there
a little almond ego and then a couple
years ago they started having almond
butter and I'm like whoa oh dang what
did they do what did they do to deserve
this they beaten them up and bothering
them up
you can picture it if you want in your
head and I don't like to picture that
kind of stuff but you could picture it
bunch of almonds getting just smashed
into each other and buttered and then
now they got almond milk now they have
almond milk and you even can you even
imagine that how are you gonna milk and
almond and call yourself a decent person
who's doing this yeah I didn't even know
almonds had glands we're taking what are
they doing can you imagine getting up
early and getting a couple almonds out
and putting a little bucket between them
and just being nasty this is guys you
know this has got to stop
I don't like a lot of the you know I
don't know man I don't know I mean I've
done shabaan I've done a bunch of shady
[ __ ] okay I'll admit that you know I've
lied to people and I've definitely I
buried a bunch of people's [ __ ]
furniture one time and I lied to him
about it but I've never I've never done
anything pervert like that to a damn nut
so if you out there milk and almonds why
don't you ask yourself who you are I
mean hell I'd rather eat I'd rather have
me I'd rather eat meat and be a regular
human and then be some just
creepy-crawler out there just you know
with two fingers out just [ __ ]
warming his fingers up searching an
almond for a damn gland him am very sad
very sad I don't know if you had I don't
know if you had the ability to see our
last episode with a sex worker it was
really really awesome man it was really
really awesome
it was a it was great it was a great
episode Alison came in and we got to
talk to her about what it was like what
it's like being a sex worker and
and just the issues that they face with
new laws and regulations and and we had
a couple follow-up calls that came in to
that some people hit the hotline you can
always be a part of this podcast of the
hotline is nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three let's get to a
couple of those calls right now here we
go hey Theo this is Ray Ray from how the
querque
rayray down in Albuquerque and I went to
a nightclub at an Albuquerque one time
and there was one lady in the club
dancing on a speaker by herself I don't
know if she worked there or she just you
know didn't like to dance at sea level
and uh and a real song with a lot of
bass came on and she she fell off she
fell off that speaker there in
Albuquerque let's hear more fighters in
the world Albuquerque is the best you
have seen you gotta you got to be able
to fight an Albuquerque they got
scorpions out there they got desert
animals they got people who you know
they got deadbeat dads who are trying to
just deadbeat others and it's a real
there's a lot going on out there a lot
of dream catchers a lot of people
selling bad art and good art a lot of
gold people still looking for gold
a lot of dehydration so if you come
across somebody that hasn't found gold
in a long time and they're dehydrated
they're gonna want to [ __ ] fight and
yes that is some of the best UFC
fighters out of there let's hear more
ray ray I'm calling in regards to your
life podcast something with the sex
worker and I thought it was a great
interview you did and I just wanted to
kind of get my opinion I personally
think that you talked about the dark art
the porn drug addiction I think that
this can whatever you want to call it I
think it's no different from any drug
addiction porn addiction I think it's
all dark arts whether you want to say
it's immoral from a biblical perspective
from a societal perspective I just don't
think it's healthy and I think you
brought up a good question that if
everybody's going to prostitutes where
does that leave the family unit right
where's the
trust where is that that intimacy in the
family if everybody's cheating on their
wives and and that's their aspiring to
do that because it's okay
as much as dear sex worker wanted to
legitimize her profession I just don't
think it's right so people can maybe go
in there and get out but I think some
people get trapped and that's just my
opinion
thank you for this space for your
callers thank you for listening through
our calls you're awesome and I just want
to say namaste and thank you
Thank You ray-ray I appreciate you
calling there's a good points there's a
great points man you know it even makes
me feel it doesn't make me feel ashamed
of uh it makes me feel yes if we are if
people are using sex workers then then
they're not bringing that they're not
bringing that Chi back into the
household
you know if they're not bringing that
Chi back into their nest if they bust a
net nudie down the street you know down
at some you know down it you know
allison's Chi Hut or whatever you know
and they you know they feeding that
other Chihuahua
down the street then they're not keeping
that you that that that lust and that
that that energy in their own household
and and you're right it is a dark heart
it is a dark art I think part of one of
the reasons I wanted to interview her
was to get the side of the story of what
it's like for sex workers who were not
sex traffickers who are not sex traffic
victims and just how some of the new
laws and regulations have affected them
now I do think that long term some of
those laws in it could be good because
if it's not an option for women to
advertise themselves then we'll some of
those women get out of that industry and
find something else to do I don't know I
don't know if there's been enough
studies that show that I don't or I just
don't know that information but yeah
it's like you're deaf you know I've had
friends that have thought about cheating
on their wives and they'll talk to me
about it and and then they and then they
and they haven't
and they and the reason they haven't is
because they want to keep that energy in
their household there's something
special about coming back to your bed
and lay in there with your spouse and
knowing that you guys are a team that
you guys are in it together that you
guys are in it to win it if it's good or
if it's bad you're playing the game
together and I'm not saying that that's
not a great thing I'm not saying that
that's something you know that I believe
in my heart I would love to have in my
own life but if people are you know if
you're battling with the dark arts then
you know I guess it's good that there's
an organized profession out there for
you to deal with it you know there is an
organized way to deal with it you know
now some people might deal with sex
addiction they need to go see about that
and they need to get help you know I
don't know this is a great topic man and
these are really good points and and I
appreciate you bringing them up
it definitely weakens the feint it
definitely does I mean I don't think you
can go back to your spouse or your love
when you're a girlfriend and and keep it
a hundred percent
and know that that nest that that the
egg the overall egg of comfort and
relationship that you guys are
incubating together is gonna be as as
warm if you are acting out
you know I guess I don't know I mean and
this is good it makes me think about it
man and I appreciate you calling and
making me think but it was also it was
good to have Alison in here and to hear
what it's like from her perspective
I wonder how healthy her you know her
relationship is with with uh with power
and stuff like that you know I had a lot
of questions about that that I wish I
would have asked at the time but I
didn't but thank you so much for your
call man all right let's go to another
call about the Alison's scenario as well
hey Theo this is Stacey I just wanted to
say thank you for the last podcast with
the sex worker it's really a big deal a
lot of times when that type of project
it comes up a lot of men have a lot of
bad thoughts about what sex workers do
and usually there's a lot of negative
opinions but I really appreciate yours
yeah I just wanted to say thank you
thank you for calling you're welcome you
know I just don't want to look down on
somebody if they are a sex worker you
know I don't think that there's you know
it's a job it's being done it's been
done since the beginning of time
different people's value systems are
gonna be different if you have a
situation with your spouse or your you
know wife or husband where that type of
stuff is something that you guys are
okay with each other engaging in or
something then that can be one thing you
know it's probably safer I would guess
then going out and you know maybe it
stops people that are rapers or people
that are you know lonely from devolving
into you know really really dark worlds
you know I don't know I don't know
there's a lot there
I mean it's oh it's a wild I mean these
are women that are operating on the cusp
of society but heavily operating and
there's a ton I mean it's it's extremely
popular in big cities so it's something
that's going on it's definitely
something that's going on and it's part
of our livelihood and
and and I just think we're always in a
time of transition and is sex something
that people are using as much as you
know is sex that connector that it
always was between a couple with with
everything being so sexualized now I
mean you know you look at you turn your
phone and there's 20 ads that have had
you know breasts and everything you know
before you've even seen your spouse in
the morning you've seen 75 different you
know scantily clad covered women via
advertising or via Instagram or just you
know on a television show we're on the
Newt you know it's just there's a lot of
there's a lot of sex out there and it's
almost like his sex jumped the shark a
little bit is it as as crucial for our
connections these days or is emotion
what is more important you know with sex
just seems kind of so rampant these days
and almost I don't think that it's I'm
not saying that it's valueless but it
just seems more I mean people are it
just seems to be so everywhere now that
people are just almost like fist bumping
with their crotches
whereas I felt like when I was you know
and maybe it's cuz I'm older that it was
more like okay sexist is the thing that
will connect us for life and forever
and and now it just seems I don't know
it just seems different but I also live
in Los Angeles where you know every
there's billboards everywhere and and
I'm not living back in my hometown where
you know a lot of people got married out
of high school and that sort of thing
and and there's more of a religious
backbone in the community and and I can
see I don't know it's a big it's a big
it's a big conversation there's a lot
going on and if you have thoughts on
that about you know sex and today's
society and if we're oversexed or if
we're if we've lost the value and you
know you can hit the hotline nine eighty
five six six four nine five zero three
let's take another call right here here
we go hi P oh this is Elaine from
Nebraska hey Elaine from Nebraska and
you guys's football team is the worst
sorry to tell you that I'm sure you
already knew and I shouldn't have said
that
I just kind of rude mean to say but um
but you have great people there and I've
had a beautiful time when I've been
through your your state homework
Nebraska State
yes homework I'm just calling because I
was listening to your podcast about
you're talking about how some women feel
pressure to be successful by climbing up
the corporate ladder or something and
for this reason they don't want to start
a family or have a baby and I think
that's super valid but I just wanted to
I guess was my own personal experience
has been the opposite where I feel
pressure maybe it's where I'm from to
have a baby start a family and be that
motherly figure when deep down inside I
don't feel like that person mmm I'm
whistle of my life and sometimes I just
feel like I don't want to fix what isn't
broken or and this might be my own issue
sometimes I just don't really even share
my love with him with somebody else a
baby so that could be something but I
don't want to get your thought on like I
just swing back and forth all the time
between feeling guilty for not having
that motherly inclination and I and then
other times I feel like well it's my
right to live my life the way I want to
and I really just want to have a simple
life and do the things I enjoy and it's
having a baby isn't one of those if I
should feel bad about it
just let me know what you think love the
podcast to you oh I appreciate you
calling in that's a you know that's a
lot to share and I know that probably
you know took a little bit to share some
of those thoughts and probably to
verbalize some of that you know it's
funny I think there's these templates
that are from the past you know there's
these templates like all you should get
married oh you should have a job well
you should go to college
and and I'm not to make this about me I
feel a lot of times like like I've
always felt like man should I be
settling down should I be married or
should I just you know be you know
sometimes I do just want to be by myself
and sometimes I do just want to you know
I I don't you know I get you know I get
scared of caring about somebody or I get
tired of it and I don't want to have to
think about somebody else but I get I
guess I get selfish and I don't want to
have to think about somebody else but
myself you know and I guess you know I
get scared about if I have kids am I
gonna [ __ ] up my relationship in in and
you know and she don't my spouse or be a
bad dad or you know and I get scared of
wanting to do take on those even risk
those challenges and yeah I can imagine
yeah I can imagine if you're in a place
where some place is it is more about
family which is a beautiful thing you
know to have a family and see the kids
and they're running around and they're
[ __ ] you know kicking each other and
dude I remember these two brothers they
used to you know they used to do this
game it was like you know it was called
dirty rabbit cuz rabbits do this song
you know rabbits do those little poops
kind of and they would take a they would
each get a um a Tootsie raw you know the
bit the minis do not them long daddy's
brother
these are children and they would
wrestle until they you know hit the
other one with the writing that Newt you
know in that and that little you know in
that little that tight mouth in the back
that little boot boot that booty a whole
you know and if first one to get that
little Tootsie we're all up and that
other ones booty all want it up you know
there was a champion anyway I don't know
why I'm getting onto that yeah that's
got to be scary you know you're a mind
it's got to be scary to like feel like
homes just supposed to have a kid I'm
supposed to are there other things I
want to do you know is it is it an old
design
you know have children and in pro you
know like our grandparents a lot you in
some areas especially in the Midwest
like you know you might have ten kids
two or three generations ago cuz only
seven of them were gonna live and so you
needed people to you know take care of
your crops and take care of your farming
and you needed kids as they got older to
take care of the other kids because you
know them that you needed help around
the house it was it was a different it
was a different animal and family was so
much more I think it was families were
stronger back then I would assume I'm
also romanticizing these types of things
you know I'm Norman Rockwell in a bit
here but I can I feel you when you say
that you know I think sometimes we'll
you know I could probably live a life
that would be more fun for me it would
be more maybe would it be selfish to do
that to this live my own life and never
you know settle down and have a family
you know I think about I would feel sad
if I if I didn't give like my brother
and my sister like any need any extra
nieces or nephews I think about that you
know I think about you know I would have
the ability maybe to then have a kid and
be able to love my kid more than I felt
loved so that I'd be able to complete
that thing inside of me and I don't even
think that from a selfish way but you
know if I could have a son or a daughter
and really love them you know and I
could see and know that they felt loved
and that they felt you know comfortable
and happy and that they you know woke up
in the morning and had somebody that you
know was excited to love them and care
about them all day and that they knew
they never even questioned whether or
not that I love them unconditionally
they just felt it in their vibe in their
skin and in their veins and in their
even in their eyebrows all day they felt
their fathers love that you know or
their parents love that would that
would that make me feel whole in the
spaces where I feel like I didn't get
that and I don't know if that selfish to
think of that about having kids that way
and I'm thinking obviously everything in
my own situation here but you made me
think about my favorite movie which is
Bridges of Madison County and I'll go
toe-to-toe with any dude out there he's
some dudes out there mm-hmm
saying a badass is you like Fight Club
and [ __ ] like that well how about the
original Fight Club for your heart baby
Fight Club for your emotions and that
was the Bridges of Madison County
and that's a Clint Eastwood's
and what else is her name Marilyn the
street and Marilyn's Streep is probably
one of the top 70 or 80 actresses you
know a man it's amazing because she has
she has a family and it's just regular
life and then this man comes through
town and he's a photographer you know
he's that Kodak
fasho dag boy and he's out there [ __ ]
popping off pictures and he you know he
where like he you know he looks like he
wears beardbrand that uh that old money
spray in his hair he looks real swaggy
and she just has this one weekend with
him where they ex you know they have an
expedition they just they get involved
in each other's lives and she's it's
just kind of like her one moment to try
a different lifestyle and my problem for
me young lady is you're making me think
about this I'm indecisive so I can't
tell sometimes what is me thinking about
something or what is me feeling a way
that I really feel and that gets
extremely aggravating sometimes but
these are great you know these are great
questions in the people can hit the
hotline with some of these thoughts nine
eighty five six six four nine five zero
three if you feel that come is it you
know does she she sounds like you know
she didn't want to share this sometimes
with her with their spouse you know it's
yeah wow that's a it's a what a quandary
but what so amazing of you to think
about it and to verbalize it
that's very brave but I think we are in
this time now where it's such a me time
where you know what we're all Yi you
know what I think though that that
everyone is becoming so it's becoming so
me and so automated I think we're gonna
get back towards a family type of thing
where family is extremely important
because it is it is the only place where
a lot of us will get actual real
connection I'm starting to think that
that could be some of the future but I
appreciate you sharing I don't know you
know I don't really have any suggestions
except to don't feel hurried to make a
choice and if you're unsure about you
know if you're unsure you know talk to
somebody that you know really cares
about you you know and I care I just
don't know if I have the brains enough
to be able to really help you think
about this more but I don't think that
there's anything wrong if you don't ever
have a child I don't think that at all
you know I don't think there's anything
wrong if you want to go out and chase a
dream and you want to be do to me Lee
Earhart's ii you know because the me
let's be honest in me earhart and that
[ __ ] crashed
she gets a lot of credit but uh where ya
at Amelia you know saying at least a
million but Delia like she worked you
know she at least worked hard and got a
couple of books out about you know
cleaning and like sexy outfits but
Earhart you know then she gets a lot of
credit but she can't really get it done
so you could really be the first Amelia
Earhart you could get out there in a jet
you know in a little sass and or
something and [ __ ] take your chances
and if you land in Barbados maybe you
meet you a little dark brother and
you'll have a couple of little beige bad
boys you know a couple little [ __ ]
water jockeys and get them out there but
whatever you choose it sounds like
you're a very smart young lady and then
you're emotionally aware and then I bet
you're gonna make really great choices
for yourself and and thanks for letting
us even think about things that you are
thinking about okay we also had some
calls that came in through our videos
and you can see those on YouTube and you
can go to this past weekend calm and
there's links on there where you can
submit video questions to come in to the
podcast and let's get to two of those
right now here we go
hey Salman this is Tim Raven from the UK
and the UK that's United Kingdom and and
if you can't see this man but he is
laying it see Mike in a bed and have he
might not have a shirt on but he does
have on a either a small watch or a
wristlet onward just put it back round
one 22 years old living at home with my
parents
I've got a decent job financially my
parents aren't doing so well with money
shoddy things how how do I help them
financially without them thinking I'm
bailing them out or you know being a big
shot I know this isn't a big problem
that's what a lot of others that have
caught in that I just need to know man
and keep you doing what you're doing I
love you keep and
everyone awesome and keep it up thank
you very much Tim for calling in man you
know it is tough it's tough to know when
you can help your parents when you
cannot you know I think one way an
option would be to go to you know maybe
your father because he's the other man
there's just a suggestion bro
I don't know you know I gave a you know
recently I you know and I've talked
about this but they had a man my mother
worked for a man and he wasn't and that
man wasn't treating my mother good you
know my mother delivered she's a
delivery lady and she delivers magazines
and newspapers and this man made her
work out in the Sun and lifting these
heavy bundles and [ __ ] like that
and and he told her there would be
someone there to help her and there
wasn't somebody there and a man knew it
you know he's a snake and um and you
know my mother's hard worker she'll work
she'll work she'd dig her own grave I'll
still be at her funeral she'll get up
out the coffin dig her own grave and get
back in you know that's how she is and
and then anyway but I I ended up you
know I said I sent my mother a thousand
bucks I never had the money to send her
a thousand bucks before and I sent her a
thousand bucks you know and I told her I
just said we you know I want to help out
because somebody's not treating my
mother like that you know another man
isn't treating my mother like that
anymore
you know what I'm saying I can help take
care of my mother now and now I don't I
didn't offer to sit you know and I told
her I said if you need help I'm here
that's what I said and so now my mother
knows if a she needs help that she can
ask so then it puts her in a it you know
it lets her know a little bit that
somebody is there she doesn't have to
feel alone now in your situation you
have both your parents I would go to
your father you know maybe go to your
father and say hey Dad
you've done so much for me I want to be
able to help out some you know I don't
want to tell mom because you know you're
the man of the house but as your son you
know you've done so much for me
that I would like to be able to
contribute would it be okay with you if
I contribute to you or or something like
that that way your father can still
present it to the family if he wants to
and it saves his face with your mother
not that he needs that or whatever but
it just puts you in a city it still
keeps you in your space where you're
requesting to help and you're requesting
out of not out of obligation but out of
desire you know out of desire because
you learned it from your dad you can
even put it like that to him now if your
dad is the kind of guy you know is not
gonna allow that I respected you maybe
you go through your mom and see if
there's a way to do that unless you feel
like if your dad found out he would be
very upset or you could even sit on both
down because you know the real value
your parents man I asked and I learned
this from a caller this is a while back
a caller called in and said that the
best thing you can do is is just wanna
help the fact that your parents know
that you want to help that they raised
the type of boy Tim that wants to help
others and that wants to be a
contributing son that's gonna make them
feel richer than anything you could give
them you know that's what they really
want they just want you to be happy
that's what they want I guess and I've
never been a parent but that's what they
want they really want you to be happy
and you could say maybe then well one
thing that would make me happy will be
really being able to contribute to the
household so those are maybe just some
ideas are going about it but I think
it's sweet that you even care man you
know a lot of young people they just
think you know they want to get in
arguments with their mom and then they
want to leave and I've been that person
you know I'm being angry at my mom for
the wait but you know I'll sit around
when I had extra you know and I wanted
to hold a grudge against my mother
something like that and maybe someone
who was deserved I don't know you know
who knows different times in my life
but when I get to the end of my life and
you know I look back yeah I just wanna
you know I guess you always want to have
been able to help your parents um but I
don't know thank you for making me think
about this man and and thank you for
caring about your parents broad think
it's really really sweet let's take
another call they came in to to the
video fan line here we go I was going
Theo von my name is Daniel right sorry
if it's a bit loud right now I'm calling
from work and this is Daniel from work
and he looked like him on red earmuffs
that are really hard and sometimes you
see hard hard earmuffs on somebody if
they work at the airport or if they are
you know mentally challenged sometimes
and uh you know sometimes a long time
ago homeward I called Dublin Ireland
Dublin Ireland dude I love Ireland a
freaking love Ireland brother the Pogues
brother I think they're Irish and I love
Ireland man and I love you dude and if
you crack my if you crack open my
ribcage you saw my heart I bet it's the
shape of damn Ireland brother onward my
question is what are you going to be for
Halloween and what do you think about
the whole star is selling Christmas
decorations in [ __ ] September October
now you could be walking around getting
candy with the kids and [ __ ]
come across a house with Christmas
decorations please thank you for calling
man thanks for the video you know what I
say this about the Christmas you know
Christmas I'm already ready
I still have [ __ ] up in my living room I
never took down brought from 7-8 years
ago I got a [ __ ] you know I got a
dusty rain be a little dusty reindeer
ornament right under the edge of my bed
and that thing been collecting dust
since you know probably last year I'm
all about it brah I'm saying if I wake
up in the middle of the night and step
on a [ __ ] Christmas ornament glass
when it breaks under my feet I smile
baby cuz I like the holidays you know I
love Christmas man thinking of a [ __ ]
fat boy rolling through the sky in an
old-school sleigh bruh with a couple of
[ __ ] snow donkeys pulling that [ __ ]
come on son that that is I mean that is
just cocaine right there but how do I
feel about it man let me think about
that that's good I mean you know I like
Halloween I'm glad that they have it I
think kids need to be scared at least
once a year on a group level and I think
it's great man when I was young they had
a dude you know they had um they had
this family they had a trick-or-treat
and you know and they would put the
stuff by their house and they had to
walk across this huge field it was about
a half mile in the middle of the field
they had all these electric fences and
you couldn't see them because it was
dark so you're walking you got your
candy next thing you know you getting
shook you're getting shook out you drop
your candy maybe you faint or whatever
you don't even know you wake up you
think it's damn Easter bruh you don't
even know what's [ __ ] going on and
then they would come in in the morning a
school ball ball of candy that the
children dropped so Halloween I'll tell
you this for Halloween one thing you
don't want to be for Halloween is Santa
you know every now and then you got that
shady dude who try to dress up like
Santa for Halloween and try to jump the
gun bruh you know I'm saying he trying
to jump the calendar gun all the way up
to December 2/5 you know I'm saying he's
that Dec to Fizi bad B
but let me tell you it is man last time
I saw it at it do got jump okay a couple
of people that you know a couple of
[ __ ] Thanksgiving bad boys [ __ ]
jumped him stuff this Turkey you know
what I'm saying put that for game you
know drip drip drip drip just dripping
fists on him brothers rémoulade nin bruh
so be careful if you try to skip a
holiday somebody might [ __ ] you up you
know it reminds me when I was young for
Halloween somebody tried to dress up
like a deaf kid in our town you know any
wore a turtleneck and AH and just you
know I think that was it but he was
trying to look deaf and then a real deaf
kid beat his ass so you got to be
careful you got to be careful man you
know but I grew up in that area where
people didn't treat the Deaf really well
you know they had a deaf kid in our town
and some kids beat him up one time for
doing bad magic you know because he was
always doing all of this you know the
sign language but you know he never
pulled out a quarter never pulled out a
dove and people beat his ass because
they thought he was doing bad magic so
if you got a deaf kid you know buy him a
dove get him a 30 or 40 dollar dove
could save his life but for Halloween
what am I gonna be man you know I think
i'ma wait and see you know maybe I'll be
a Japanese guy riding on an asteroid you
know maybe I'll be a leg you know maybe
I'll be a lesbian man put me on a little
you know brassiere or something in tempt
you know get out there and tempt the
ladies or dino duke instructions
I don't know that's a good question man
but I'm already ready for Christmas man
I'll let you guys know that I'm gonna be
in Charlotte North Carolina in two weeks
then I'll be in Appleton Wisconsin
Phoenix Arizona Buffalo New York Salt
Lake City in Washington DC washington DC
sold out already but they're adding a
sunday show over there in the nation's
capitol and we might try to add in
another city or two here there I'm so
grateful to everybody that's come out
you know my career has really been
changing this year and um and we'll talk
about it more in the future but it's
just been you know it's just been wild
man it's just been wild and uh and I've
been having to stay humble and trying to
humble myself and just make sure I know
where I'm at in my own space you know
just make sure I know what's going on
with me and that's been an interesting
experience let's take a few more
you know people called last week uh we
talked to a guy named Casper whose
brother had passed away and um and you
know it was really sad and I tried to
reach out to him I had the wrong number
and then I tried him again so I'm
waiting to hear back from him but uh but
let's take a call or two about that hey
Theo this is Allan calling from
Washington State
hey Allan thank you guys for calling you
guys almost beat USC this past week and
in my heart you beat them okay in my
mind you beat them
okay go Cougars homeward um I just heard
the podcast and I want to sit in the
Casper you're not alone brother I lost
my book my big brother three years ago
and I just want you to know man that
you're not alone and it gets easier
I know it's hard right now it gets
easier and it gets better and you
mentioned the memories those memories
may seem hard right now but maybe a
month maybe two months maybe a year
maybe three years from now you're going
to love those memories you're going to
love sharing them
and I hope you do
I hope feel can connect us and we'll
leave my phone number at the end but
you're not alone and your brother loves
you too and I lost my brothers for the
same disease and I'm the sent
[ __ ] every day but yeah man
anyway Gang Gang man that pull uh that
pulled that sea salt spray right out of
my eyes man thank you for calling
thank you for calling Manas a really
really sweet of you you know cuz I know
it's probably hard to talk about that
you know cuz then you got to think about
your own situation
it's nice heat not to let Casper know
that he's not alone you know it's hard I
feel must have shamed even talked about
this a little because um you know cuz I
still have my brother you know my
brother's alive you know my brother is
um you know my family struggle with
addiction a lot and uh my brother's
still alive and I'm very sorry to you as
well call her you know that you lost
your brother wow what a powerful
statement to share that the memories
right now that are painful
be you know we'll be some of your most
prized possessions at some point
and you know what's so funny man you
know I was listened I'm you know I'm
sitting here there's the first time I
heard this call this is the first time I
produce her Nick put it in he told me
the episode you know there's you know
there's some you know some real stuff in
it but when you said that your brother
loves you man that got me
you know and that's what just made
there's something powerful in
being there for each other there's
something powerful and sharing our
stories there's something powerful and
not letting other people feel alone and
you called because you don't want Casper
to feel alone man I think that's really
really beautiful and I don't know your
brother
I don't know Casper's brother either but
I I bet he's really proud of you today
man I bet he's proud of you always you
know that you care enough to call and
say that sort of thing that takes a man
and that takes a man and I will connect
you guys whenever I talk with Casper
Allah I'll connect you guys it's very
nice of you and I don't know what else
to say I think I don't think there is
anything else to say on that I think
he's said enough you know I'm gonna
leave that where it is you can always
hit the hotline nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three let's go let's
go to a call right here uh we'll go to
one more call and let's see what's going
on
homeward hey feel boy Gavin up in
Montana
hey brother thank you for calling from
Montana onward just want to let you know
I'm a big fan going through some dark
times right now set up pretty bad
problem with alcohol for the last many
years I'm 28 years old
27 I got a beautiful little two-year-old
boy and I had a wonderful woman but all
my drinking and stupid decisions I
didn't put family first and pretty much
severed the ties with a woman who once
really adored me for who I was
despite all my flaws and trying to get
sober straight down my life it'll be
that good dad that's my little boy needs
and I just want to tell you man
your podcast helps me get through the
day every day at work I just really
appreciate all your insight and all your
jokes ma'am
and uh yeah I've been sober for five
days now well I guess 5:00 tomorrow and
uh I'm gonna try to keep it going and
just we're still living under the same
roof we have a house together and it
makes it hard when we're separated last
weekend I went on a 48-hour bender and I
made some stupid decisions man and it
just that was it and it ruined I think
any chance of us ever reconciling
anything and I don't know how peer from
you you know
suggestions advice whatever whatever you
got for me man thanks for calling thank
you for calling congratulations on the
five days you know if you still have it
you know I didn't I don't know when this
week this this call came in if you don't
have it that's okay you can start back
over you know the cool thing about you
know sobriety and that sort of thing is
that it's always there for you you could
have two years you could drink again you
could go back it's always there for you
[Music]
you know do one of the things that I
don't believe in the world is that a
leopard never changes its spots
I think that's one of the biggest
misconceptions that there is you know I
do believe that people can change you
know I've seen it in my own life you
know I grew up like I used to not care
about you know I used to not have
relationships and care about people
because I didn't know how to and because
I couldn't feel that others cared about
me and that's changing in my life and I
feel it man and I see it happening and
it's scary and it's amazing and I never
even imagined that that could occur you
know uh Ron eclis I feel like the calls
that we got before with these men that
lost their brothers you know like you
want you know you don't want to be that
for uh you know you don't want your son
calling in here
years from now
we'll be still on air 17 years from now
no you know you can do it bro
I'll say I'll tell you you can do it
can do it man you can change you I love
the fact you said that she loved you
unconditionally even despite your flaws
and your faults and that's not going to
change you can do it it can get better I
can't tell you if you are an alcoholic I
have no idea I can't tell you if you
really have a problem I do not know but
I do know that
that my life changed for the better and
continues to do so the longer that I
don't use drugs and alcohol
and
[Music]
it's obvious just that you care man you
know you care about yourself you know
and you know you got somebody that loves
you the heart that sometimes there's
something wrong with uh with alcoholics
where we can't feel people's we can't
feel people's love the right way we
can't feel it we can hear it and we can
say oh I know you love me but we can't
feel it correctly and so if we can't
feel it correctly we don't act we don't
always behave like it exists and that is
one of the problems I remember I hear
yeah people say oh I love you know I
care about you yeah thank you thank you
I appreciate you know I care about you
but I couldn't really feel it because
there was something in wrong inside of
me and that continues to get better that
thing that was wrong continues to get
better and I can feel people's love for
me bruh and there has been no greater
I mean it's like Star Wars bro you know
when I feel that like you know when
somebody tells me that they love me and
I can actually feel it
I mean I didn't I didn't know that
that's what that was I didn't know what
that was at all I didn't know how that
worked and you know through the program
I getting help I'm able to feel that
more now and I still struggle but I
don't struggle as much as I did but you
can do it man I promise you you know I
check in with you this week and see
what's going on you know maybe if you're
in an area where I know somebody I could
connect you with somebody or whatever
and if you don't want to answer my call
and everything that's okay too you don't
have to feeling the obligation I don't
want you to feel any obligation but
but I do want you to be happy you know I
do feel like you deserve to be happy and
it seems like you want to be happy and
mate you know who is the woman the right
woman for you you don't know who knows
you know there's a lot I mean a lot of
that stuff that you can figure that out
but if you start to find some ways to
take care of yourself man you're gonna
take care of everything else you know
when you got to take care of yourself
but I appreciate you calling man I you
know sometimes I got listened to the
call now I'll listen to the whole thing
and you know I don't even know what to
say
but it makes me think like
no I didn't know my dad very well you
know because my dad was so old and I was
such a just a little boy you know my dad
was born in 1910 and I was just a little
boy and uh I think you know my dad
struggle with alcohol you know he'd been
abused a bit by you know some of the
women in his life and not you know and I
think he might have had some issues but
you know sometimes I wonder if he would
have called into a place and you know
and said he wanted to be a better man
for his kids you know and if I'd have
known right now that he did that in his
life that would make me think of him a
certain way it made me think oh wow he
had a heart you know he was a caring man
you know he once called in and and
professed that he wanted to be a better
man so he could care about me better and
so you just did that and that's pretty
powerful man you know so that's pretty
powerful that you are that kind of dad
you have that ability I don't know if
I'm making sense sometimes but man I
don't even know what to say me you guys
have kind of said a lot today you know
this one kind of went all over the place
and I don't even let's uh let's take
another call right here man let's take
another call right here here we go oh
yeah this is Nick I'm Phil Adelphia
what's up Nick from Philly and if you
look at my hat right here I got on that
hood hat and they're not even one of our
sponsors on this episode but I got that
hood hat for and it says South Philly
and you can go to Hood hat USA or follow
him on Instagram they got all these
swaggy hats that are more based on your
neighborhood then they are just like you
know just instead of saying go Eagles or
whatever thanks for calling let's hear
more so I'm 23 years old and I just got
open-heart surgery oh dang they cracked
open in them a ort huh you got that open
heart surgery damn would they find bro I
bet there's a bad in there
imagine they crack you opening a [ __ ]
bat flies out dude
that's Edgar aorta Poe onward so pretty
a mobile for the next now about seven
eight weeks and where I used to for a
good time you know I loved going to ask
bars grab a drinks but I don't think
that's quite a good move yet so yeah you
can't say I mean you could tell a girl
look you know I want to give you my
heart and you could actually crack that
thing open and show her now that's a
pick-up line be like oh yeah you want
another way to my heart and she's like
yeah and you're like just crack that
arse that our cz bro that ribcage a just
crack that French frickin you know crack
open that French bone door that uh you
know that marrow la port just cracked
that thing open and just so just so your
heart so show her your heart
so show her that that that tik tik
hombre Oh looking for a hobby I was
wondering what do you think is a good
way to fill my time you know a little
bit more bedridden than usual all right
man get that hitter well get that ticker
bro for you what's a good way to fill
your time as a hobby you know that's a
really good question man if I had a lot
extra time I think I would start doing
some more reading you know people give
semi books a lot and give me books and I
wish I could read more of them I saw a
focus more on reading mmm a good hobby
for you if you were in the hospital you
could flirt with the nurses bad boy you
know what I'm saying they got this thing
on the internet I think it's like a um
it makes it sound like you're dying it's
in you know it makes the flatline sound
and so then the ladies come running in
so you could you know put a couple of
pillows under the you know under the
gurney or whatever they come running in
to help you and then maybe you you know
you know maybe you are or or don't
or do this lay under the sheets but have
you freaking you know have done you know
that meat piece hanging off to the side
a little you know and then they come in
and they they cover yourself up fully
with a sheet they ripped the sheet down
and they see that frickin that Lincoln
Log you know looking around they see
that thing oh he might be dead but you
know but his penis is still Abraham
thinking about some Wasi some real
quality out there but you know what is
it good hobby
man I don't you know I don't really know
dude I don't know you got a hot you know
I don't know man honestly I'm kind of
overwhelmed with just some of the calls
that came in today and I don't mean to
not think about that i but think about
your call but I'm just a little bit
overwhelmed Oh cuz I don't know what a
good hobby is hmm you could probably go
to the kids area in the hospital if
you're gonna be in the hospital and draw
pictures or something with them what's a
good hobby
you can make a cool youtube video about
what your experience is like we're
getting a heart a heart issue or like
that a heart surgery and put that on
YouTube in case somebody else is scared
about the experience you can kind of let
them know what what it's like you know I
think that kind of stuff does help
people a good hobby
I don't know Manas be good yourself
you know just triumph just trying find
ways to stay humble man you know try to
be true to yourself think about you know
think about your life what do you want
your life to be like do you want to have
a family maybe one day do you not want
to have a family maybe one day get in
touch with the instincts you know if you
got our brother call him and tell him
that you love him you know if you'd only
have a brother but if you got a sister
and she got some strong sideburns or
whatever call her tell her hey if you if
you were a man I would love you like a
brother
you know call your parents up and ask
them if you could do something to help
are they doing okay financially would it
be okay if you helped some if you can
and as I'm saying all these things man
I'm not telling you to do them but these
are things that I'm thinking that I can
even do in my own life and these are
things that I hear from these calls
today you know I could talk to Allison
the sex worker and just make sure that
she's okay with you know why she's doing
her job and she's you know I didn't ask
her if she's so angry at men that you
know she has to feel like it's some sort
of a power thing you know I could have
asked her probably more if she does she
ever feels lonely
we could have got into it on some deeper
levels with her to see what was going on
there
you
yeah I can call my brother
I love
you know
you know I can uh I can pray for my
friends and family and you know other
people that are out there that are
struggling with addiction
you know I can call my mom
just trying to be loving and not trying
to be argumentative even if I want to be
somewhere inside of me
because she's lived a long life and
she's not a perfect person and neither
am I
and when was maybe the last time I
called up and didn't give her any grief
about how she's spending her day or how
she's spending her money or what her
plans are but just let her know that I
cared you know asked her if I could do
something to help I don't know man
you know I start these episodes dude and
I don't know where we're at and then I
get to the end and I don't know
and I
I just feel an artist feel like I'm not
alone
like in the beginning I don't know where
I'm at but at the end I don't know where
we are at
and mana said it sounds like we're still
it sounds like it's still lost but
before I was lost by myself and now I'm
lost I'm lost as a group and that seems
a lot more hopeful I got one more I had
I got to do here you know what I'm gonna
play this song and I'll do the ads after
I feel like we can use this song right
now this one's by Bishop gun as well
you
I've seen home in about a hundred days I
can almost hear mama bleep for my
restless soul and now he made a dollar
night spell but where it's going ain't
you me and I still get wet I'm bound to
go
you
how bacon wrong
[Music]
bacon
you
and most all of my plans slip right
through my hands round up next to me
[Music]
spiral wasn't our glance I'm slaving off
about it I will cast a minute
I should've put it down
[Music]
but how
feel right
[Music]
we are
good times
making good times man making good times
yeah man I
yeah I'm just um you know a few
bad like you know some of the people out
there that are struggling I was shocked
you know I wish I could help more and
[Music]
but just know that people are thinking
about you and that you are not alone and
like this tough sometimes but you are
making it and that there is a reason
that you're going through what you're
going through wherever you are in your
life is where you're supposed to be and
it's part of your journey and I believe
you know that that this all ends really
really well even though it's it can be
tough right now
it all ends really really well and that
could be that you see your loved ones on
the other side you know
but if you got a chance and you can
still see them here man then you see
them here you know I'm just grateful to
be a part of this episode and to be
learning from each other thank you guys
for being a part of this past weekend we
have are at a lass dad I have his um
better help better help calm better help
better help calm professional and
affordable counselling you can get
matched with the counselor who's right
for you
I checked out better help before I
recommended it to you guys one thing
I'll try to always do on this podcast is
not sell you things that I don't believe
in or not to advertisements that I don't
support you know people have sent us
things and said advertise this and I say
you go advertise that you know I'm
saying you go ask the devil to advertise
X I'm selling Oh jump and I'll always do
my best I might fail sometimes but I am
NOT to better help calm I checked it out
you can you can talk to a therapist
about stuff you can have a Skype
sessions with therapists you can talk on
the phone you can just even just text
with them
there are ways if you don't have a way
to talk to a therapist about something
you need help with then you can get help
it's available worldwide just go to
better help calm slash Theo
that's better help calm slash Theo you
can send messages schedule schedule
video and phone sessions professional
and affordable counseling they may take
insurance they may not I don't know you
know ask questions or whatever you have
for them I don't know anything else I
just know that it's a good organization
and that I did try it out myself
thanks man look we've been here a lot
thank you to the people that came out in
Toronto a lot of calls came out II can
get to those and that's okay
we'll get to them in the future
and I'm gonna take us out I'll just play
making it again you know and uh and
thank you guys for calling man you guys
be good to yourselves
you probably deserve it
[Music]
but I'm in good shape